Avengers: Endgame's relatively light body
count surprised a lot of fans.
Shocked by its predecessor's carnage, audiences
braced themselves for loss.
Thankfully, the majority of Earth's heroes
survived the latest encounter with Thanos,
which raises a new question: why?
It doesn't really seem like there's one right
answer.
Endgame gave us a ton of heroes, and the filmmakers
likely had different reasons for keeping each
survivor off the chopping block.
Here's why we think the following Avengers
survived Endgame.
Everyone's favorite trash panda came out of
Avengers: Endgame relatively unscathed.
The easiest and most likely answer to the
question of Rocket's survival is Guardians
of the Galaxy Volume 3.
At Hasbro HASCON 2017, Guardians writer/director
James Gunn told fans he had an origin story
for Rocket that he planned to tell.
He also warned Rocket' s life story would
likely be more "horrible" than it was in the
source material.
By March 2019, Gunn was confirmed as directing
the movie using his screenplay, so all things
considered, it looks like we might be learning
more about Rocket's past in Guardians of the
Galaxy Volume 3.
It would be a pretty big bummer if we only
got to see that story after Thanos turned
him into a small rug.
Unfortunately we didn't see a lot of Okoye
in Avengers: Endgame.
She's in the final battle and briefly speaks
to Black Widow in the beginning of the film.
Beyond that, she's absent.
Fortunately, that also seemed to increase
her overall chances of surviving through the
movie's end.
In Infinity War, T'Challa's last interaction
with Okoye is pretty memorable:
"Up.
This is no place to die."
In a way, this moment is also the answer to
her survival in Endgame.
Okoye is part of the MCU as a whole, but she's
particularly important to the Black Panther
franchise.
If she were to ever make the ultimate sacrifice,
it should be in a Black Panther film.
Not only that, but the aftermath of Infinity
War and Endgame leaves us with a lot of questions
about Wakanda and we're probably going to
need Okoye to get some of those answers.
After all, while the people who were snapped
were brought back to life, they still did
disappear, which means T'Challa was effectively
dead for five years.
The king of Wakanda died without an heir and
his sister Shuri was dead as well.
What happened in Wakanda during those five
years?
Who is T'Challa going to find on the throne?
Valkyrie was one of the most asked-about absences
from Avengers: Infinity War.
Along with Korg and Miek, we never see her
during Thanos' attack on the Asgardian refugee
ship and we didn't know if she'd survived
the purge.
Avengers: Endgame finally gives us our answers:
Along with the rest of the surviving Asgardians,
Valkyrie settles in New Asgard.
With Thor wallowing in depression, alcohol,
and Fortnite when Avengers: Endgame begins,
someone has to take charge.
So the once-apathetic warrior we meet in Thor:
Ragnarok, who once only cared about kidnapping
refugees and drinking...becomes the de facto
Queen of New Asgard.
Her contributions don't stop at the administrative;
she also flies in on a winged horse in the
final battle against Thanos.
Valkyrie's star is rising.
Considering Marvel's statements about increasing
diversity in its films, and the fact that
Valkyrie is a bisexual woman of color, not
to mention that regardless of her sexuality
or ethnicity she was a hugely popular part
of Ragnarok, the character has massive potential
in the post-Endgame MCU.
Killing her off so early would be a huge waste.
Captain Marvel's ticket sales broke many records,
and continue to break more, and there's definitely
going to be a sequel, so the idea of killing
her off in Avengers: Endgame would have been
pretty nuts.
Beyond Captain Marvel's own franchise, Avengers:
Endgame opens an opportunity for the hero
to perform another role: leader.
Endgame left a huge void in the Avengers'
leadership; Captain America is now eligible
to join AARP, and Black Widow and Iron Man
are dead.
If the Avengers are going to move forward
they'll need a new leader, and those are shoes
the Carol Danvers has filled in the comics.
We're pretty certain the big screen version
could do the same.
Thor was another hero a lot of fans guessed
was going to get the axe.
His entire family is dead, his hammer got
shattered, his people are practically extinct,
and his home exploded.
"We can rebuild this place.
It will become a haven for all peoples and
aliens of the universe."
Why wouldn't the thunder god make another
suicide run at Thanos?
What does he have left to live for?
Well, for one thing, better movies.
Taika Waititi's Thor: Ragnarok revived the
whole Thor franchise, before that, Chris Hemsworth
had apparently grown bored with the character.
But now the sky's the limit, which is exactly
where Thor is headed.
He hops aboard the Benatar toward the end
of Endgame to join the Guardians of the Galaxy,
so does this mean we should expect Thor to
be a part of the Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
3?
Or is what he said to Valkyrie true; are the
Guardians just giving him "a ride," maybe
to another Waititi-directed Thor film?
Or is this the last time we should expect
to see the Odinson outside the comics?
We don't know, and Hemsworth says he doesn't
either.
Regardless, the potential is there, and that's
enough to keep him alive.
"Cool?
Cool."
"So cool."
Rhodey was pretty much right at the top of
the list of characters most people expected
to die in Endgame.
He's a sidekick.
He had a shot at a solo film that never materialized.
His superhero name is one of the least family-friendly
titles you could think of.
"War Machine was a little too aggressive,
alright, this sends a better message."
And to top it all off, Thanos did kill him
in the comics, and not that long ago.
During an ill-fated assault on the Mad Titan
in 2016's Civil War II, Thanos put his fist
through War Machine's chest.
If you're not a comics reader but you saw
Endgame with friends who are Marvel Comics
fans, you can bet they were worried when Thanos
headed for Morag while Rhodey and Nebula were
there trying to get the Power Stone.
All of that is precisely why Rhodey survives
Endgame.
During the span of the four films they've
directed for Marvel Studios, Joe and Anthony
Russo have proven their mastery at going against
expectation.
They're not going to kill Rhodey when everyone
is thinking they're going to kill Rhodey.
Considering what we've seen from them, they
probably put Rhodey on the Morag team because
they knew fans would be seeing skulls as soon
as Thanos set course for the rock.
Nebula's survival was one of the most surprising
outcomes of Endgame.
She has a "hack first, think later" attitude
that never serves her well against her powerful
father.
She's impulsive, damaged, and suffers a well
of endless rage.
"I thought you were the biggest sadist in
the galaxy."
"That was when daddy was paying my bills."
In Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2 she flies
a spaceship into a cavern while trying to
kill Gamora, and she keeps going even after
the wings break off.
If there's one thing the Hulk teaches us in
the opening scene of Infinity War, it's that
your head better pack as much of a punch as
your fists if you're going after Thanos.
All in all, Nebula seemed doomed from the
start.
But she survives Endgame.
At least, the Nebula of the present survives,
her past self gets a hole in her chest.
One of the reasons Nebula survives is likely
the same as Rhodey; the expectation of death
was high, so the Russo brothers went in the
opposite direction.
But probably the biggest reason is her potential
in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3.
On one hand, if Nebula were to die in Endgame,
then Mantis would be the only woman left on
the team, since the whereabouts of 2014 Gamora
are unknown.
On the other, Endgame changes Nebula dramatically.
She's spent years with the Avengers and with
Rocket.
She's played paper football with Tony Stark.
The Nebula we meet in Vol. 3 will be a very
different cyborg than the one we're used to.
Marvel's Green Goliath was expected to be
headed to the gladiator arena in the sky after
the story broke that Mark Ruffalo filmed five
different endings to Avengers: Endgame.
Once the much more articulate version of the
Hulk slid on the new Infinity Gauntlet, it's
likely fans were worried this was going to
be the end for the Jade Giant.
But it wasn't meant to be.
He gets a nasty burn on his arm, and the last
time we see him he's still wearing a sling,
but Bruce Banner gets to live to see the aftermath
of Endgame.
One possible reason for the Hulk's continued
existence might be found in the most recent
rumor about Disney+'s MCU original series.
While nothing's been confirmed, shortly before
Endgame's release a report circulated that
a Hulk and She-Hulk series was in development
for the upcoming streaming service.
In the comics, it's Bruce Banner's cousin
who becomes She-Hulk after he's forced to
save her life with a blood transfusion.
Whether those details will remain the same,
or if the series is actually in development,
remains a mystery.
But it could prove to be the reason the MCU
Hulk survived saving half the people in the
universe.
Things look really bad for Cap in Endgame.
Once Thanos starts shredding his shield with
that huge double sword, it seems like he's
finally going to get to visit Peggy Carter
and the Howling Commandos in the U.S.O. show
in the sky.
Now, Chris Evans' contract is up and if there's
an unwritten code of comic book laws somewhere,
one of those rules is that when Cap's shield
breaks, all bets are off.
Thankfully for Cap, Peggy, and all of us,
Steve is still with us, though he's a bit
older.
Once the big, final battle is over, Cap uses
his assignment to return the Infinity Stones
to their rightful places in the timeline to
also return to the love of his life, Peggy.
An aged Steve Rogers hands off his shield
to Sam Wilson, and so ends the saga of the
MCU's original Captain America.
It's almost unthinkable to end Cap's journey
any other way.
To simply kill him, even in some glorious,
heroic manner, isn't enough.
Just as Tony Stark deserves his rest, Steve
Rogers deserves the chance to live a full
life and finally get that dance with Peggy.
"Figured I'd wait."
"For what?"
"The right partner."
And with two other founding MCU Avengers dying
in Endgame, we needed at least one to get
a happier ending.
The only thing Hawkeye does better than shoot
arrows is fool audiences about who's going
to die.
In a 2016 interview, Aaron Taylor-Johnson,
who played Quicksilver in Avengers: Age of
Ultron, said that one of the reasons his character
dies saving Hawkeye is that director Joss
Whedon was playing with the widespread belief
that Hawkeye would die in the sequel.
Directors Joe and Anthony Russo seemed to
use a similar strategy for Avengers: Endgame.
Hawkeye and Black Widow are tasked with getting
the Soul Stone, meaning one of them must sacrifice
themselves for it.
Hawkeye seems the perfect choice.
With his despair about the horrific things
he's done since the purge, he barely seems
like a candidate for a happy ending.
Instead it's Black Widow who dies for the
Stone.
Hawkeye also survives because he has more
work to do.
In early April 2019, Variety reported that
a series featuring Hawkeye was in development
for the upcoming Disney+ streaming service.
That's likely not the biggest reason, though.
After all, Black Widow has an upcoming film,
and neither Vision nor Loki receive Endgame
resurrections despite similar upcoming Disney+
series.
Perhaps the chief reason Hawkeye survives
is his family.
For his wife and children to be resurrected
at the end without Clint to welcome them,
would be too tragic a note for a story already
rife with grief.
Spider-Man's death scene = Avengers: Infinity
War was one of the most gut-wrenching in a
sequence filled with death scenes.
"I don't wanna go.
I don't wanna go, sir.
Please."
Surprising no one, he returns after the Hulk
uses the Infinity Stones to reverse Thanos'
purge.
He's a major player in the final battle against
Thanos and his forces, being one of the Avengers
to secure the Infinity Gauntlet from the Mad
Titan until he inevitably gets it back, but
loses all the same.
Of course, the fact that we all saw the Spider-Man:
Far from Home trailer months before the release
of Endgame was a big hint that Peter would
not only come back, but survive the film.
To anyone who wasn't sure the purged heroes
of Infinity War would return, T'Challa's death
was one that should have convinced them.
With Black Panther proving to be one of Marvel
Studios' most successful films, the first
superhero film to be nominated for a Best
Picture Oscar, and writer/director Ryan Coogler
already working on a sequel, it was obvious
the King of Wakanda couldn't stay dead forever.
Which isn't to say his death in Infinity War
is meaningless or without stakes.
In spite of his resurrection, by the time
Black Panther 2 hits the screen, Wakanda will
have gone at least five years without its
king.
Not only that, but T'Challa is lost at a crucial
time in the nation's history when, at T'Challa's
direction, it moves away from isolationism
and reveals its technological superiority
to the world.
We don't know who, if anyone, was on the throne
in T'Challa's absence, Ramonda, maybe M'Biaku.
The nation he returns to in Black Panther
2 will likely be very different from the one
he died fighting for in Infinity War.
People were not happy with Doctor Strange
after Avengers: Infinity War.
In spite of Strange telling Tony that surrendering
the Time Stone to Thanos was "the only way,"
once he gets back to Earth, Stark accuses
Strange of quote, "giving away the stone."
Bruce Banner doesn't seem very happy with
Strange either when he tells the Ancient One
about what he did.
Of course, in the end it turns out that the
one timeline in which Thanos loses needs Tony
Stark alive.
The fact remains that Strange did give up
the Eye of Agamotto, which means the forces
of Kamar-taj have lost their greatest weapon.
Thanos destroys all of the Infinity Stones
before Thor kills him, but even after some
time travel hijinks that return all the Stones
from the past to their respective times and
places so that nothing is disrupted, the Time
Stone will still be destroyed.
The relic that allowed Strange to outwit Dormammu
[door-MAH-moo] is gone, and Kamar-taj needs
Doctor Strange more than ever.
Of course, none of that would matter if there
weren't going to be any more Doctor Strange
films, but on that score we don't need to
worry.
In December 2018, The Hollywood Reporter broke
the news that Doctor Strange director Scott
Derrickson was poised to return for the sequel,
and Cumberbatch seems just as eager to return
to his Sanctum.
The end of Endgame proves to be a new beginning
for Sam Wilson.
While the Avengers expect Captain America
to return from his time jaunt as planned,
instead an aged Steve Rogers appears, wearing
a wedding ring and waiting for Falcon so he
can pass on a heavy burden to the much younger
hero.
Sam Wilson is poised to be the new Captain
America, as he was for a time in the comics.
He seems reluctant to accept the shield at
first; when Steve asks how the shield feels,
Sam says "Like it's someone else's."
Once Steve responds "It isn't," Sam takes
a long, deep breath and thanks his old partner.
On one hand, Falcon's death would be problematic
considering he and Bucky are about to share
a miniseries on Disney+.
More importantly, Falcon can't die because
the legacy of Captain America needs to live
on in younger hands, and for many reasons
it couldn't be Bucky.
Forget Black Widow, that guy's got way too
much red in his ledger.
Before seeing Endgame, you could hardly blame
anyone for putting Bucky in their Avengers:
Endgame death pool.
He isn't exactly the most popular superhero,
and considering the blood-soaked past he wrestles
with, it's easy to imagine the former HYDRA
assassin would see death as a welcome respite.
The Winter Soldier's most predictable role
post-Endgame would have been as the new Captain
America, considering Chris Evans' MCU exit
and the fact that Bucky took up the mantle
of Captain America for a time in the comics,
but we now know that honor went to Sam Wilson.
The Falcon's going to need some guidance in
his new role, and as much as he and Bucky
haven't gotten along in the past, Bucky's
probably the best choice for Sam's partner.
Speaking with Entertainment Weekly, the Russo
brothers confirmed that Bucky knew about Cap's
plan to go back in time to get back the life
he lost when he plunged into the ice.
Considering Bucky seems unsurprised by Cap
handing the shield over to Sam, it seems likely
the two also discussed what needed to happen.
We're probably going to see what that help
looks like in the upcoming Disney+ Falcon/Winter
Soldier series.
"You couldn't have done that earlier?"
"I hate you."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.